of a warm Hannity Studio welcome to
president Trump's attorney Joe takapina
all right let's first of all have you
spoken to the president yes reaction
he's ready to fight you know he's the
toughest guy I know and he's um he was
shocked you know because we really were
I was shocked I mean I've never been
angry in my 32 years in this business
both as a prosecutor and defense
attorney I've never been more angry
about a charge because today the rule of
law in the United States of America died
it's dead it's dead and it's um
something that I I never thought I'd see
I have Goosebumps even saying it because
I don't feel good about saying it you
know when you stretch the law to get
someone you don't like or as a political
opponent in this case
it's very hard to ever get that law to
come back to its original shape you saw
the ad of Alvin Bragg when he was
running what does that tell you about
equal justice and application of our
laws in this country that was his first
priority I mean he didn't have any
information any evidence but you know
again that was Nazi Germany that was
Soviet Union that was communist China
where you pick the target the person you
don't like the political opponent and
then you find the crime
it's not that way and it never was that
way in the United States of America it's
not supposed to be that way and when we
start doing that we're no better than
those other
um horrific horrific you know uh
dictatorships and governments that that
abused rule of law America always had
the justice system to protect our
citizens whether they were popular
citizens or unpopular citizens they
always had the justice system now
today's proof that you could actually
pick a Target and then try and find a
crime even a crime that's not a crime
because there is no crime here so I'm
telling you there is no crime I know the
facts I know the law and I really want
to see where this is going to go we're
hearing that the president uh may be
arraigned Tuesday has that been arranged
it's not finalized we are discussing
with them you know obviously there's a
group called The Secret Service that's
involved now I mean this is going to be
something we've never seen the likes of
no we've never seen this never happened
in our country before everybody
understands that right the president's
never been indicted and as as a former
president even a foreign president and
and and to do I've heard this you don't
bring a case like this against a former
president on a petty allegation on a
completely legal civil uh civil
transaction with attorneys
unless you have the goods unless you
have something substantial I mean to go
to the extreme of bringing down a former
president to try and indict a former
president is something that you know you
have to have like a video of him
committing a crime not some cobbling
together a couple of nonsense
allegations legally we have issues here
we have the statute of limitation issue
one example
a select the prosecution that's going to
be here I mean this is a legal agreement
that he made that Michael Cohen actually
made and Michael cohenstein Trump didn't
even sign this great things happened
that I thought would end this case Bob
Costello on this show Bob Costello
testified before the grand jury uh the
second thing is the letter from Michael
Combs attorney uh that was exculpatory
that I just read and Michael cohn's own
statement that Echoes that sentiment the
third thing was Stormy Daniels in
writing admitting there wasn't hush
money that they didn't have an affair
and even here's the here's the kicker
guys even if everything they both said
was completely true right whatever
version of truth because you know
Michael Cohen is a walking contradiction
he is pathologically incapable of
telling the same story twice I bet
you're very nervous going up against him
I'm horrified I'm really
I'm gonna be so nervous when I stand up
the cross exam I'm like it might be the
easiest course because I might have to
have to pay president Trump to do that
gross examination instead of the other
way around I mean that guy has has a
pathology don't make that deal no I
don't he's already got a hold because
that's already done her but he has a
pathological need for media attention
here is someone who pled guilty to a
slew of criminal conduct and and not
just not just the hush money thing he
pled guilty to lying to Congress lying
to the banks in his taxi Medallion fraud
uh you know now of course the FEC IRS
um so he's a pathological liar and you
know he supposedly now Reborn
and he's on MSNBC every night and he's
their big star and I I wonder about you
know the fact that he's on MSNBC every
night yet he's now saying in his book he
was only forced to plead guilty he
really didn't do it so he's not even
accepting responsibility I'm gonna have
a field day with him and then but he
pled guilty he pled guilty but he's
saying he was forcefully guilty to
protect his wife let me ask you this so
it's being reported tonight in places
34 separate charges 34 counts you know
for sure
with less than always
um The New York Times told us today that
he was indicted and then we got
confirmation from the DA's office
um we now heard 34 counts I guarantee
it's going to be 34 counts when we find
out next week right
um on what they'll take each check and
make that account perhaps and and that's
how they'll do it because the checks
paid to Cohen but you know they're
embracing Michael Cohen as their witness
in this case their star witness this is
really one of the most disgraceful human
beings in our history
some testimony of Costello how does he
overcome the how about a letter from his
own lawyer his own testimony previously
bone statements on television his his
repeated lies and then here's a guy we
have a tape of this man actually saying
to a reporter
you can rape your wife it's not crime to
rape your wife he actually said this
I've seen that I've seen that I just
wanna re vomit but you know the people
who are watching him on MSNBC and
applauding him
are very strong me too movement people
and very strong time out people but yet
him making a statement like that where
he said well the law allows you to do
that which by the way Michael Cohen's
never been known as really a lawyer he
clearly missed that day of law school
because the law does not allow you to
yes your wife so just to let everybody
know what is happening next week Donald
J Trump will be arraigned yes there'll
be a mug shot he will be fingerprinted
will he be handcuffed no
will he be Park walked I'm sure they're
going to try and do that of course
everything they've done here is to gain
attention it's not for the right motives
there is no one that could ever convince
me that this man was not just charged to
affect the elections the effect of free
election in this country and that's
scary to me that is scary to me well he
calls it the new election interferences
it is it's election interference
that's why they brought this case and so
far by the way according to the polls it
has exactly been playing out the way
they expected it to last question will
this backfire this will backfire because
we're going to win this case we will
humiliate them and they will they will
they will pay the price they will pay
the price for bending the rule of law
justice will prevail in this case at one
point I'm sure of it Sean Joe takapina
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else